listen uh congrats on the movie I
thought you guys did such a great job
with this thank you so much
so good uh so but I'm curious this is
the first time you've made a movie on
like this scale it's my first movie in
general
exactly yeah crazy so
so my question for you is what surprised
you about the actual process of making a
movie on like this scale and being part
of a production that's like so massive
yeah I mean I think like the beautiful
it's a beautiful ecosystem you know like
there's thousands of people working on
this one project and they're giving a
heart and soul into it and I I just feel
so blessed and honored to to have been
uh a part of it and have been able to
contribute uh myself into it
um but I think it's just so cool like
you know I I again I'm constantly
working with so many people right like
so many people in the costume department
so many people in the visual effects
department so just the stun team is
massive like it's just so so so cool and
you are really working with pros and and
it's it's a constant I was like a sponge
every day taking everything in learning
um just excited and and just so finally
excited to share to get to share this
with you that you've you've seen it and
I can't wait till it comes out so
everyone else can see it one of the
things that the film does so well one of
the many like it balances the action
with humor but it keeps everything
grounded with Barry focusing on his mom
and I'm curious what are you most
excited about everything that's in the
movie for audiences to see I think the
movie has a lot of heart
um I think ultimately every every
character
has really deep complicated feelings
um and it's a beautiful mix of everyone
um you know as we know like uh why it's
just so sits the superhero sadness of of
you know Batman losing his family his
parents
um The Flash also losing his family
Supergirl also understanding what that's
like losing her entire planet and her
parents
um so this movie is is kind of
prevailing it's kind of like a a um
obviously every character is going
through their own grief
um but but there's a lot of love in in
Hope and heart in this film and I think
I'm just excited for everyone to
experience the multitude of emotions the
comedy the the the anger the strength
The Joy it's just such a fun movie
one of the cool things about being in a
film like this is you get to have toys
and merch and all this you know stuff
that's in you know wherever it may be
I'm assuming you've seen a lot of this
stuff what is your favorite piece of
merch or toy that you're like I can't
believe this exists and I'm on this I
know so believe it or not I I don't get
told what gets made I have no idea what
is being made
um it like the Barbie obviously the
first thing I I saw was the Funko Pop
and it's the fans like I mean you guys
tagging me and telling me what's out
there is like the biggest blessing in
the world because I have no idea so it's
like a constant like oh my God are you
serious are they making that so the
first thing was the Funko and then
obviously after my mom found a link to
the Supergirl Barbie and that was
wild I was like are you sure that's me
are you what is happening like this is
incredible and insane and I immediately
bought it and I I received it and my
face is on the box of the Mattel Barbie
doll box which is insane
um as one of the most iconic superheroes
I I love Supergirl so much and I I look
up to her and I think that she's she's
an iconic and strong and hopeful
character uh you get to fight Zod in the
movie you were obviously much younger
when Man of Steel came out ah I saw it I
saw it of course of course no no yeah I
know you saw it but I'm saying like like
when you were watching Man of Steel
obviously you have no effing idea what
your future life you know I know I know
like so what was it like when you
finally realized what or Andy told you
you're gonna fight Zod Michael Shannon's
coming back you know all of that the
coolest thing in the world I mean Man of
Steel is an incredible movie
um Michael
Shannon is is an incredible actor he's a
legend I didn't realize till later on
that we share the same birthday which I
think is really cool
um but literally until like a year after
we wrapped it was like my birthday the
following year and Barb and Andy were
like it's also Michael Shannon's
birthday I was like shut up that is like
the coolest thing ever
um but no he he's an icon I I really uh
he was So Graceful and dumb he was
always connected to me
um he gave me everything and every scene
even when the camera was on me and he
was off camera he gave it to me over and
over and it was such a blessing to work
with him
um and and to to bring that world of Man
of Steel to to experience it to to have
played Supergirl it was it was a very
very cool experience and
um I think uh Michael Shannon for for
giving me uh his Zod at full full always
what sequence I'm assuming that when you
were filming this uh there had to be
certain tough days in terms of filming
and I'm curious which sequence in the
film ended up being like the real pain
in the ass to film and why
um I guess the real pain in the ass but
by pain in the ass
meaning
my body was hurting a lot but I was
having a lot of fun
um was The Silo scene it was like about
a week of of me at The Silo scene and
um I was really blessed and honored to
to uh Eunice who was our stunt
coordinator allowed me to do my stunts
and so I I was exhausting I just have
this I love stunts so much and they give
me this like adrenaline and I love the
fighting I love becoming
um I love learning like just getting
better at it
um so those were very exhausting days
like
um my little brother was with me and and
after you know the adrenaline rush your
body
kind of
gets it you just like crumble and I had
to do like 30 minute bath uh salt uh
salt baths every night and I had to set
an alarm and that's like a tough work
you know a bath is like sounds very nice
and is really like but it's imagine
every night you gotta like put salt in a
bath and you have to sit there for 30
minutes and time yourself so there was a
lot of of um
healing that I needed to do as well but
it was it was an incredible experience
and alongside me I did have Jade and
talila and Eunice to to to be with me
and support me through through those
through that whole week and
um I love that scene so much it's
fantastic
um obviously every film has deleted
scenes I'm always curious did you have
any deleted scenes yes just just like I
think just like the uh The Silo The Silo
scene was a lot longer
um yeah so there was a lie did a lot of
stunts for that scene and some I think
were a little too rated R
um
and um they ended up kind of you know
bringing it in
um but I I I I just because there's so
many visual effects but maybe one day I
can ask Andy to like let me see them
because it was so
um there were so many and and I just you
know as much as I love stunts I would
love to see it I would love to see the
wholeness of of those shots totally on
that note I gotta rap I'm just gonna say
congrats I really do hope the film's a
huge hit for you thank you so much thank
you thank you thank you